Jake:买了
Jake: Bought it.
其他人：已经有了
Others: Already got it.
Jake:什么叫有了
Jake: What do you mean got it?
Jake:有人已经有人买了
Jake: Someone already bought it.
其他人：那不是
Others: Isn't that...
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Haha.
其他人：我说我现在账户里已经有150个ego币了
Others: I mean I already have 150 ego coins in my account.
Jake:哦牛批
Jake: Oh, impressive.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Nice, nice.
Shure: 然后呢然后我们怎么分发呢
Shure: So, how do we distribute them?
Shure: 最后会有有
Shure: In the end, those who have a Matt mask will get some.
Shure: 有这个Matt mask的就分
Shure: And those who don't, won't, right?
Shure: 没有的就不分是吧
Shure: Is that it?
其他人：我的想法是
Others: My idea is...
其他人：最后
Others: In the end...
其他人：今天大家每个人最后手里有多少个ego币
Others: Today, everyone will get as many ego coins as they have in hand.
其他人：我就给你们发多少个
Others: I'll distribute that amount to you.
Shure: 那怎么发呢
Shure: But how will we distribute them?
Shure: 那万一有人没有这个钱包呢
Shure: What if someone doesn't have a wallet?
其他人：发钱包也不
Others: Giving out wallets...
其他人：要钱
Others: Doesn't cost money.
其他人：但我不知道这个
Others: But I don't know...
其他人：发钱包会不会要燃油费啊
Others: If distributing wallets will incur a gas fee.
其他人：也他妈发一个
Others: Just send one.
其他人：ego币不要钱
Others: Ego coins don't cost money.
其他人：燃油费他妈
Others: But gas fees do.
其他人：那没事我还有还有点余额
Others: It's fine, I still have some balance left.
Shure: 知道这是干什么的吗
Shure: Do you know what this is for?
其他人：测温的
Others: For measuring temperature.
其他人： 那你加一个面包我要先吃一下
Others: Then add a piece of bread, I want to eat first.
Shure: 我有
Shure: I have it.
其他人：别他妈刷彩个逼
Others: Stop messing around.
Shure: 还其他人：手续费
Shure: And... Others: The transaction fee...
其他人： 我真不懵
Others: I'm really not confused.
Katrina: 你知道这这孔怎么打开吗
Katrina: Do you know how to open this hole?
Jake:应该是有一个针
Jake: There should be a pin.
Jake:它应该是有一个它
Jake: It should have a... it...
Jake:它就一个这个东西吗
Jake: It's just this thing, right?
Katrina: 嗯刚刚就把他下面这一环给撕了
Katrina: Hmm, I just tore off this ring below.
Katrina: 但是好像没有送针啊
Katrina: But it seems like there's no pin included.
其他人：感觉从这个
Others: Feels like from this
其他人：呃
Others: Uh
其他人：我们的成本上这币每个都已经3块钱
Others: Our cost for each coin is already 3 bucks
Jake:有点贵有点稍贵
Jake: It's a bit expensive, kinda pricey
Jake:嗯你知道怎么开吗这东西
Jake: Hmm, do you know how to open this thing?
Katrina: 真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Katrina: 其实我觉得说的有道理
Katrina: Actually, I think it makes sense
Katrina: 直接剁就行
Katrina: Just chop it directly
Jake:这什么东西
Jake: What's this thing?
Shure: OK了来吧
Shure: OK, let's go
Lucia: 看起来像烤红薯
Lucia: Looks like roasted sweet potato
Jake:哦哦可以我拿了
Jake: Oh oh, alright, I'll take it
Jake:我靠这红薯长成这样
Jake: Whoa, this sweet potato grew like this?
Lucia: 嗯对他确实是烤红薯
Lucia: Yeah, it really is a roasted sweet potato
Shure: 你手里有五个吧
Shure: You have five in your hand, right?
Shure: 押我100块
Shure: Bet me 100 bucks
Shure: 如果今天
Shure: If today
Lucia: 啊这个银耳雪梨汤
Lucia: Ah, this is white fungus pear soup
Lucia: 它里面竟然是整颗雪梨
Lucia: It actually has a whole pear inside
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 我去
Lucia: Wow
Lucia: 这比巧克力宣传整颗榛子还离谱
Lucia: This is even more outrageous than chocolate with whole hazelnuts
Lucia: 因为它真的是整颗雪梨
Lucia: Because it's literally a whole pear
Lucia: 你看我一捞上来我就惊呆了
Lucia: Look, I was shocked when I scooped it up
Jake:吃应该比较好分吧
Jake: Should be easier to eat, right?
Jake:要自己分就很离谱
Jake: If you have to divide it yourself, that's crazy
其他人：最后一次
Others: One last time
Katrina: 我需要充电宝
Katrina: I need a power bank
Shure: 我给你们系江带
Shure: I'll tie you guys up
Jake:但是我们没什么充电宝
Jake: But we don't have many power banks
其他人：这他妈得多少钱啊
Others: How much is this gonna cost?
Jake:你要不找一个叉子
Jake: Why don't you find a fork?
其他人：嗯这也不便宜
Others: Hmm, it's not cheap either
Jake:你要不找一个固定的叉子
Jake: Why don't you find a fixed fork?
Jake:你要是你活动
Jake: If you're moving
Katrina: 在外面
Katrina: Outside
Jake:你在外面
Jake: You're outside
Lucia: 鲜银耳炖整梨
Lucia: Fresh white fungus stewed with whole pear
Lucia: amazing
Lucia: Amazing
Shure: （歌词）darling just kiss me slow
Shure: (Lyrics) darling just kiss me slow
Jake:来整俩充电宝
Jake: Let's get two power banks.
其他人：只要我靠谱
Others: As long as I'm reliable.
其他人：这个币就有价值
Others: This currency has value.
Jake:你怎么靠谱
Jake: How are you reliable?
其他人：因为我现在就必须得
Others: Because right now, I have to...
其他人：记住每个人多少钱
Others: Remember how much everyone has.
其他人：我没办法直接给他们
Others: I can't give it to them directly.
其他人：啊直接给他太多
Others: Ah, giving it directly is too much.
Jake:那那怎么办
Jake: Then what should we do?
其他人：活动结束了给
Others: Give it after the event.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 都给你录下来了
Shure: I recorded everything for you.
Jake:哎这是啥呀
Jake: Hey, what's this?
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 我看看
Lucia: Let me see.
Lucia: 咦
Lucia: Eh?
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 看起来好像可以用的样子
Lucia: Looks like it can be used.
Jake:呀yes
Jake: Yeah, yes.
Lucia: 我可以现在把它摘下来安一下吗
Lucia: Can I take it down and install it now?
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Lucia: thank you
Lucia: Thank you.
Jake:走拿快递去
Jake: Let's go pick up the package.
Lucia: 嗯又可以去拿快递了
Lucia: Yeah, we can go pick up packages again.
Jake:呃因为他
Jake: Uh, because he...
Jake:有很
Jake: Has a lot...
Jake:你看你看他的快递你看他的快递
Jake: Look, look at his package, look at his package.
Tasha: 昨天没有人替我拿
Tasha: No one picked it up for me yesterday.
Lucia: 昨天我的也没拿
Lucia: No one picked mine up yesterday either.
Lucia: 所以我就专门去
Lucia: So I went specially to...
Lucia: 拿了一趟
Lucia: Pick up a set.
Lucia: 对哦当时应该把薇薇的一块拿上
Lucia: Yeah, I should have taken this one too.
Lucia: 我以为他们给你拿了呢
Lucia: I thought they picked it up for you.
Lucia: 就是那个民宿的
Lucia: The guesthouse one.
Tasha: 谁给我拿了
Tasha: Who picked it up for me?
Lucia: 民宿的
Lucia: The guesthouse.
Lucia: 本来民宿的
Lucia: The guesthouse was supposed to...
Lucia: supposed to拿我们所有人的快递
Lucia: Supposed to pick up all our packages.
Jake:是的
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 你昨天应该说一声
Lucia: You should have said something yesterday.
Lucia: 我要知道你没拿我们就跟你一块去
Lucia: If I knew you didn't take it, we would've gone with you.
Tasha: 我给他打电话了
Tasha: I called him.
Lucia: 领导这是你的你的问题了
Lucia: Boss, this is your problem.
Lucia: 领导你反思哈哈
Lucia: Boss, you need to reflect, haha.
Jake:嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake:我反思反思
Jake: I'll reflect on it.
Lucia: 我那这么说来他们昨天就没拿几个
Lucia: So, they didn't take much yesterday.
Lucia: 咱俩那一串都没拿对吧
Lucia: We didn't take the whole string, right?
Lucia: 就那个民宿
Lucia: At that B&B.
Jake:你昨天发的那一串他啥也没拿是吧
Jake: The string you posted yesterday, he didn't take anything, right?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Lucia: 我也
Lucia: Me too.
Lucia: 我觉得民宿
Lucia: I think the B&B...
Lucia: 他们这个工作态度要提升一下呀
Lucia: They need to improve their work attitude.
Jake:有问题
Jake: There's a problem.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:下一次去三亚就不找他们了
Jake: Next time we go to Sanya, we won't use them.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 我们真的要去三亚吗
Lucia: Are we really going to Sanya?
Lucia: 我还没有去过
Lucia: I haven't been there.
Jake:你没有去过
Jake: You haven't been?
Lucia: 没去过
Lucia: No, I haven't.
Jake:没去过走
Jake: Never been? Let's go.
Lucia: 所以您要是在三亚做实验的话
Lucia: So if you do experiments in Sanya...
Lucia: 你看我这个工作态度和效率怎么样
Lucia: How's my work attitude and efficiency?
Jake:哈哈哈可以可以
Jake: Haha, not bad, not bad.
Lucia: 哈哈哈老板你考虑一下
Lucia: Haha, Boss, think about it.
Shure: 什么什么时候去三亚呀老板
Shure: When are we going to Sanya, boss?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:什么时候去
Jake: When are we going?
Jake:五一之后去走
Jake: After May Day, let's go.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Lucia: 真的吗
Lucia: Really?
Jake:真的吗
Jake: Really?
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Lucia: 我哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure: 你等我答完辩的
Shure: Wait for me to finish my defense.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Okay.
Tasha: 不等
Tasha: No waiting.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 我正好正好公费度蜜月去了怎么样
Shure: I'm going on a company-paid honeymoon, how about that?
Tasha: 公费度蜜月你还要把你女朋友带上
Tasha: A company-paid honeymoon, and you still have to bring your girlfriend?
Shure: 我们干活效率都很高
Shure: We're very efficient at work.
Tasha: 哦是你啊
Tasha: Oh, it's you.
Tasha: 想看看是哪位男生
Tasha: Just wanted to see which guy it is.
Alice:啊累死我了
Alice: Ah, I'm exhausted.
Tasha: 你女朋友在北京吗
Tasha: Is your girlfriend in Beijing?
Shure: 啊是的
Shure: Yeah, she is.
Tasha: 哦是他的
Tasha: Oh, his.
Tasha: 在西安
Tasha: In Xi'an.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Tasha: 啊什么
Tasha: What?
Tasha: 我说是他的在西安
Tasha: I said his girlfriend is in Xi'an.
Lucia: 谁女朋友在西安
Lucia: Whose girlfriend is in Xi'an?
Tasha: 他女朋友啊
Tasha: His girlfriend.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: 想认识一下美女小姐姐
Lucia: I'd like to meet this pretty lady.
Tasha: 呵呵怎么回事
Tasha: Haha, what's going on?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 因为我在西安
Lucia: Because I'm in Xi'an.
Tasha: 我知道我说他怎么不说话哎
Tasha: I know, I was wondering why he wasn't saying anything.
Shure: 哎那你会说陕西话吗
Shure: Hey, do you speak Shaanxi dialect?
Lucia: 我会
Lucia: I do.
Lucia: 但我说的可能不那么标准
Lucia: But maybe not that well.
Lucia: 不过北方话反正本来就是变个调
Lucia: But Northern dialects are basically just tone changes anyway.
其他人：陕西话感觉挺好听
Others: Shaanxi dialect sounds pretty nice.
Lucia: 怎么了要我说一段吗哈
Lucia: What's up, you want me to say something in it? Haha.
Jake:来来一段
Jake: Go ahead, say something.
Shure: 绿辣子6馍
Shure: Green chili bun.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈你这舌撒的咋听不懂啊哈哈
Lucia: Haha, your proShure's GFciation is so off, I can't understand a word! Haha.
Shure: 绿辣子6馍
Shure: Green chili bun.
Shure: 什么那个
Shure: What's that?
Lucia: 不知道不过我我
Lucia: I don't know, but I, I...
Lucia: 因为我们家一般不说山西话
Lucia: Because at home we usually don't speak Shanxi dialect.
Lucia: 就是只有只有我姥姥姥爷那一辈的
Lucia: Only my grandparents' generation does.
Lucia: 他们才说山西话
Lucia: They speak Shanxi dialect.
Lucia: 对其实我在家其实也说普通话
Lucia: Actually, at home we usually speak Mandarin.
Lucia: 就是说的就说的
Lucia: So, like, so...
Lucia: 不是很标准
Lucia: It's not very standard
Lucia: 但是我同学都说
Lucia: But my classmates all say
Lucia: 说的还可以
Lucia: It's pretty good
Lucia: 但是可能是同学给我给面子你知道吧
Lucia: But maybe they're just being nice to me, you know
Jake:很标准了
Jake: It's very standard
Shure: 完了武林外传的味上来了
Shure: Oh no, the flavor of "My Own Swordsman" is coming up
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 佟掌柜哈哈哈
Shure: Tong Shopkeeper, hahaha
Shure: 你今天要不就一直这样
Shure: Why don't you just keep doing this today
Shure: 我进来要来了呢
Shure: I'm coming in
Jake:要回大掌柜吧
Jake: You have to return to the head shopkeeper
Jake:要不啊呵呵呵
Jake: Or not, hahaha
Shure: 你你比如说那个那个有有客人来了
Shure: You know, for example, when a guest comes in
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Shure: 你会怎么说
Shure: What would you say
Shure: 用用那个山西话啊
Shure: Using that Shanxi dialect
Shure: 不是陕西话
Shure: Not Shaanxi dialect
Lucia: 吃馍还是吃还是吃啥
Lucia: Do you want to eat steamed buns or what
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Lucia: 俺也不知道
Lucia: I don't know either
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Alice:他说下午统一取
Alice: He said to pick them up in the afternoon
Alice:下午不就晚了
Alice: Isn't that too late
Jake:对所以我们直接自己走
Jake: Yeah, so let's just go on our own
Alice:我有两个我的都到了
Alice: I have two of mine that arrived
Jake:好吃吃吃吃
Jake: Okay, eat, eat, eat
Lucia: 我也有两个可以吃
Lucia: I also have two that I can eat
Jake:能吃都能吃
Jake: You can eat them all
Lucia: 他那里面是整颗雪梨
Lucia: There's a whole snow pear inside
Lucia: 不过已经被我吃掉了一部分
Lucia: But I've already eaten part of it
Alice:所以什么时候拿快递啊
Alice: So when are we picking up the package
Jake:现在吧
Jake: Now, I guess
Jake:哎谢斌竹帮忙
Jake: Hey Xie Binzhu, help out
Jake:这个这个
Jake: This, this
Jake:这你配过对吧
Jake: You've paired this, right
Jake:怎怎么配
Jake: How do you pair it
Jake:就是我要跟他建立一个蓝牙
Jake: I need to establish a Bluetooth connection with it
Jake:他是没开吗
Jake: Is it not on
Jake:他是咋回事
Jake: What's going on with it
Alice:好鬼畜
Alice: So weird
Shure: 河南洛阳
Shure: Henan Luoyang
Lucia: 我一会再把头发扎一下
Lucia: I'll tie my hair up in a bit
Lucia: 不然他老挡着那个摄像头
Lucia: Otherwise, it keeps blocking the camera
Shure: 俺是河南的
Shure: I'm from Henan
Shure: 河南许昌的
Shure: From Xuchang, Henan
Lucia: 这是什么呀
Lucia: What is this?
Lucia: 这好像是个蛋羹
Lucia: Looks like egg custard
Lucia: 吃这个需要放醋吧应该
Lucia: You need to add vinegar to this, right?
Lucia: 他没给吗看一下
Lucia: Did he not give any? Let me check
Jake:他包里好像还有东西
Jake: Looks like there's more stuff in his bag
Lucia: 果然小醋包
Lucia: A small vinegar packet, indeed
Jake:嗯好
Jake: Ah, okay
Jake:拿快递了
Jake: Got the delivery
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh
Lucia: 我可以申请帮我取一下吗
Lucia: Can I ask you to pick it up for me?
Lucia: 因为我要在家捡那个墙纸
Lucia: Because I need to stay home and work on the wallpaper
Jake:好嘞发给我
Jake: Sure, send it to me
Lucia: 只有两个了谢谢
Lucia: Only two left, thanks
Jake:发给我发给我
Jake: Send it to me, send it to me
Lucia: 什么不是我
Lucia: What? Not me
Lucia: 我只是下来看见他有
Lucia: I just saw he had it
Lucia: 所以我就舀出来了一点
Lucia: So I just took a bite
Lucia: 我刚才用的那个碗呢这个
Lucia: Where's the bowl I used earlier? This one
Lucia: 好热呀今天
Lucia: It's so hot today
Lucia: 哎呀妈这醋还挺酸的
Lucia: Oh my, this vinegar is really sour
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm
Katrina: 这是你的手机还是我的手机我的
Katrina: Is this your phone or my phone? Mine
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No
Alice:他们已经去取快递了吗
Alice: Have they gone to pick up the delivery?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 应该还没走吧
Lucia: They shouldn't have left yet
Katrina: 不知道
Katrina: No idea
Katrina: 天天游荡着
Katrina: Always wandering around
其他人：欸，你昨天后来用完我打火机放哪了
Lucia: 应该还在这个桌子上啊
Lucia: It should still be on this table
Lucia: 在这在这
Lucia: Here, here
Lucia: 我看见了
Lucia: I see it
其他人：OK
Lucia: 这个不过他有点不太好打着
Lucia: But it's a bit hard to light
Lucia: 所以我用了一下就
Lucia: So I used it for a bit
其他人：不太好用了
Lucia: 对感觉是你的那个棉芯
Lucia: Yeah, it feels like it's your wick
Lucia: 现在他有点就是对
Lucia: Now he's kind of...
其他人：烧脱堵了
Lucia: 你换一根棉芯应该就就好了
Lucia: You should replace the cotton core, then it should be fine.
其他人：是不是有镊子
Others: Is there any tweezers?
其他人：这镊子不是吃东西的吧
Others: These tweezers aren't for eating, right?
Lucia: 不是吧昨天靖康给我的
Lucia: I don't think so, Jingkang gave them to me yesterday.
Lucia: 应该不是用来吃东西的
Lucia: They shouldn't be for eating.
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What is it?
其他人：镊子
Others: Tweezers.
Jake:我不知道干嘛的
Jake: I don't know what they're for.
Lucia: 本来昨天打算拿它烤那
Lucia: I was planning to use them to roast that...
Lucia: 个水母蛆
Lucia: Jellyfish maggot yesterday.
Lucia: 但是有点短
Lucia: But they are a bit short.
Jake:这是啥油条
Jake: What's this, a youtiao?
Lucia: 油条
Lucia: Youtiao.
Jake:叼一个走
Jake: Take one to go.
Jake:拿快递了
Jake: Gotta get the package.
Jake:走走快递
Jake: Let's go, package time.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
其他人：雨轩
Others: Yuxuan.
Jake:在外边外边
Jake: Outside, outside.
其他人：雨轩
Others: Yuxuan.
Jake:你有一个快递对吧
Jake: You've got a package, right?
Lucia: 两个嗯
Lucia: Two, yeah.
Jake:两个好
Jake: Two, okay.
Alice:我也有两个
Alice: I have two as well.
Lucia: 我在
Lucia: I'm here.
Jake:你也有两个
Jake: You have two as well?
Lucia: 我发到你的聊天框里吧
Lucia: I'll send it to your chatbox.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 谢谢非常感谢
Lucia: Thank you, much appreciated.
Jake:没有关系
Jake: No problem.
Alice:Lucy呀你
Alice: Lucia, you...
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm?
Alice:你的弄了多少了
Alice: How much have you done?
Lucia: 我哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: 哇好好看
Lucia: Wow, looks so good.
Alice:但我觉得这个好埋汰啊
Alice: But I think this one's kind of messy.
Lucia: 好看的我觉得
Lucia: I think it looks nice.
Alice:就是这个颜色比较亮
Alice: This color is quite bright though.
Alice:这个感觉灰不溜秋的
Alice: This one feels kinda dull.
Alice:可能是印刷的问题
Alice: Maybe it's a printing issue.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 但我觉得整体的那个什么是协调的
Lucia: But I think the overall look is coordinated.
Lucia: 就是整体的色调搭配是协调的
Lucia: Like, the overall color scheme is coordinated.
Lucia: 好好看
Lucia: Looks really good.
Alice:呵呵呵
Alice: Hehehe.
Lucia: 我目前为止
Lucia: So far,
Lucia: 还只把这个桌子摆在了墙角
Lucia: I've only put this table in the corner.
Lucia: 然后在那里放了一个照片墙
Lucia: And then I put a photo wall there.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:这是我刚贴上去的
Alice: I just put it up.
Alice:我发现还是你那个纸好用
Alice: I found that your paper is better.
Lucia: 还是比那个纸好用
Lucia: It's still better than that paper.
Lucia: 嗯那个纸
Lucia: Hmm, that paper.
Lucia: 我现在在想如果我贴墙上
Lucia: I'm thinking if I put it on the wall,
Lucia: 他会不会有点小
Lucia: would it be a bit small?
Lucia: 其实我觉得这个大的更好
Lucia: Actually, I think the bigger one is better.
Lucia: 就是他的视觉效果上
Lucia: Like, in terms of visual effect,
Lucia: 会把这个房间填的更满一些
Lucia: it would fill the room more.
Alice:你买的是多大的
Alice: How big did you buy it?
Lucia: 我买的不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia: 可能不是很大
Lucia: Probably not very big.
Lucia: 因为他是那种贴画
Lucia: Because it's a sticker.
Lucia: 就他不是一整张画
Lucia: It's not a whole painting.
Lucia: 他是一个一个的
Lucia: It's individual pieces.
Lucia: 你可以自己组合着贴在不同的地方
Lucia: You can arrange them however you like.
Alice:哦那你可以稍微散一点
Alice: Oh, then you can spread them out a bit.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Alice:需要我帮你啥吗
Alice: Need my help with anything?
Alice:我现在我在等我那个大那个
Alice: I'm waiting for my big, um...
Alice:那个那个我的小窗帘
Alice: my little curtain.
Alice:蕾丝哎
Alice: Lace, uh...
Alice:不对那什么窗帘
Alice: No, what curtain...
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:我现在想怎么给它弄上去
Alice: I'm thinking how to put it up now.
Lucia: 你这个你这个床罩好好看
Lucia: Your bedspread looks so nice.
Alice:那你可以玩摸摸
Alice: You can touch it if you want.
Alice:无所谓的
Alice: I don't mind.
Alice:可以坐上来玩
Alice: You can sit on it and play.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Alice:反正他还得估计再一会去呢
Alice: Anyway, he's probably going to leave in a bit.
Lucia: 好舒服
Lucia: So comfortable.
Alice:这个床裙我很喜欢
Alice: I really like this bed skirt.
Alice:就这个底下这个
Alice: This one right here underneath.
Lucia: 嗯好看的
Lucia: Yeah, it's pretty.
Lucia: 我本来也想买一个床罩
Lucia: I was thinking of buying a bed cover too.
Lucia: 但是我发现蓝色色调的床罩不好买
Lucia: But I found out that blue bed covers are hard to find.
Alice:很难买我看了
Alice: Yeah, they're really hard to find. I checked.
Lucia: 对非常非常不好买
Lucia: Yeah, they're very, very hard to find.
Alice:并且颜色不好看
Alice: And the colors aren't nice.
Lucia: 就是不好看
Lucia: Yeah, they don't look good.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Exactly.
Lucia: 除非就是哎
Lucia: Unless, you know...
Lucia: 咱俩这很像
Lucia: Ours are quite similar.
Lucia: 不过我觉得你这大小合适
Lucia: But I think yours fits perfectly.
Lucia: 我那稍有点大了
Lucia: Mine is a bit too big.
Alice:我量我量了一下我这个是40直径
Alice: I measured mine, it's 40 diameter.
Lucia: 然后他就
Lucia: And then he...
Alice:然后就买了个60的
Alice: Then I bought a 60 one.
Lucia: 我是你的同款
Lucia: I got the same model as yours.
Lucia: 不过颜色不一样
Lucia: But in a different color.
Alice:你买的啥颜色呀
Alice: What color did you get?
Lucia: 蓝色的
Lucia: Blue.
Alice:这个真的很好看
Alice: That one looks really nice.
Lucia: 嗯打算把这桌布也带回家去
Lucia: Yeah, I'm planning to take this tablecloth home too.
Alice:这个就用完就可以带回家了
Alice: You can take it home after using it.
Alice:要不然留着干嘛
Alice: Otherwise, what's the point of keeping it?
Lucia: 应该是可以的
Lucia: Yeah, you should be able to.
Alice:这个地毯很贵
Alice: This carpet is expensive.
Alice:花了我好多预算
Alice: It cost me a lot of my budget.
Lucia: 这是tufting的做的地毯吗
Lucia: Is this carpet made with tufting?
Alice:不知道应该不是
Alice: I don't know, probably not.
Lucia: tufting就是那种毛毛毡的
Lucia: Tufting is like that fuzzy felt kind.
Lucia: 呃跟跟普通的
Lucia: Uh, like, compared to regular ones...
Alice:那个大毛线突突突突突的那个
Alice: That big yarn kind that goes puff puff puff.
Lucia: 对对对对对
Lucia: Yeah, exactly.
Lucia: 看它有点像
Lucia: It kind of looks like it.
Alice:应该不是
Alice: Probably not.
Alice:感觉这是工厂的那啥
Alice: Feels like it's from a factory.
Alice:因为他反面是那种啥啥的工厂货
Alice: Because the back side looks like some factory-made stuff.
Lucia: 嗯好看的
Lucia: Mm, it looks nice.
Alice:你需要做什么东西吗
Alice: Do you need to make something?
Alice:我可以帮你
Alice: I can help you.
Alice:虽然我有点累了
Alice: Although I'm a bit tired.
Lucia: 嗯主要是咱们这剪刀很很急缺
Lucia: Mm, mainly, we're really short on scissors.
Lucia: 我要把那个就是墙画再剪一下
Lucia: I need to cut the wall art again.
Lucia: 因为我那个就他
Lucia: Because, you know...
Lucia: 本来他是直接撕下来就贴到墙上的
Lucia: Originally, it was supposed to be directly stuck on the wall.
Lucia: 但我害怕贴到这的墙上
Lucia: But I'm worried if we stick it...
Lucia: 万一到时候撕不掉就很麻烦
Lucia: It might be hard to remove later.
Lucia: 所以我要把它剪下来
Lucia: So I need to cut it out.
Lucia: 然后用美纹纸贴
Lucia: And then use masking tape to stick it.
Lucia: 让我先上去把它拿下来
Lucia: Let me go up and get it first.
Alice:要不你在我这弄吧
Alice: How about you do it at my place?
Lucia: 也可以或
Lucia: That works too, or...
Alice:我这还放了香薰嘞
Alice: I have a fragrance here too.
Lucia: 我看看昨天晚上那个剪刀
Lucia: Let me see the scissors from last night.
Lucia: 我剪那个啥
Lucia: I used them to cut...
Lucia: 我剪那个塑料瓶用了一下
Lucia: I used them to cut the plastic bottle.
Lucia: 可能雨轩在用看看
Lucia: Maybe Nicous is using them, let me check.
Lucia: 咦雨轩你有看到那个剪刀吗
Lucia: Hey Nicous, have you seen the scissors?
Katrina: 没有所有人都在找剪刀
Katrina: No, everyone's looking for the scissors.
Katrina: 那个蓝色的吗
Katrina: The blue ones?
Katrina: 蓝色的可能在二楼
Katrina: The blue ones might be on the second floor.
Lucia: 有一个那个叫什么颜色
Lucia: There's one, what color was it...
Katrina: 红色吗
Katrina: Red?
Lucia: 有一个不知道从哪里出现的
Lucia: There's one that appeared out of nowhere.
Lucia: 剪刀是透明的
Lucia: The scissors are transparent.
Katrina: 啊那我没见过
Katrina: Ah, I haven't seen that one.
Lucia: 那个好用一点
Lucia: That one's better.
Lucia: 啊好的谢谢
Lucia: Ah, okay, thanks.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 奇怪
Lucia: Strange.
Lucia: 那我再找一下
Lucia: I'll look for it again.
Lucia: 嗯会在哪里呢
Lucia: Hmm, where could it be?
Lucia: 我记得我昨天晚上还用了
Lucia: I remember using it last night.
Lucia: 嗯Excuse me
Lucia: Hmm, excuse me.
Lucia: 我觉得我是不是
Lucia: I think I'm...
Lucia: 嗯这个天气有点暗
Lucia: Hmm, this weather is a bit gloomy.
Alice:我感觉我上火了露西
Alice: I feel like I have a fever, Lucia.
Alice:我的鼻子好痛
Alice: My nose hurts so much.
Lucia: 嗯多
Lucia: Yeah, a lot.
Alice:我的牙龈也好痛
Alice: My gums hurt a lot too.
Lucia: 多喝点水
Lucia: Drink more water.
Lucia: 我觉得我也有点
Lucia: I think I have a bit too.
Lucia: 而且我就是一直会想打喷嚏
Lucia: And I keep wanting to sneeze.
Lucia: 为什么又找不见剪刀了
Lucia: Why can't I find the scissors again?
Lucia: 好烦啊
Lucia: So annoying.
Lucia: 严重拖慢我的进度
Lucia: It's seriously slowing down my progress.
Lucia: 本来是进度就不怎么快
Lucia: My progress wasn't fast to begin with.
Lucia: 莫非能在楼上吗
Lucia: Could they be upstairs?
Lucia: 我昨天没用他的呀
Lucia: I didn't use them yesterday.
Lucia: 我就在楼下最后用了一下
Lucia: I only used them downstairs at the end.
Lucia: 然后我就没用了
Lucia: And then I didn't use them anymore.
Lucia: 不知道呀
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia: 好奇怪呀
Lucia: So strange.
Lucia: 我上楼看一眼
Lucia: I'll go check upstairs.
Lucia: 这要剪不好那我就GG
Lucia: If I can't cut this right, I'm done for.
Lucia: 这个是雨轩
Lucia: This is Yuxuan's.
Lucia: 的小灯难道在这吗
Lucia: Little lamp, could it be here?
Lucia: 也不在我靠
Lucia: 嗯
Alice:你找到了吗
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: 我就觉得应该不会在楼上
Lucia: 因为我昨天晚上在楼下用的
其他人：What  are  doing  here
Lucia: 我在找一个剪刀
Lucia: 你昨天有在这里看
Lucia: 或者今天早上
Lucia: 在这看到一个透明色的剪刀吗
其他人：No
Lucia: 嗯奇怪
Lucia: 到处都没有哎
Lucia: 啊那我怎么办
Lucia: 离大谱了没有
Lucia: 好奇怪我昨天晚上在那里用的
Lucia: 然后就还放在那了
Lucia: 好怪啊
Lucia: 理论上说他应该
Lucia: 他应该不可能不见呀
Lucia: 咱这饮料可真多呀
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Lucia: 把美工刀给他放架子上去工
Lucia: Put the utility knife back on the shelf.
Lucia: 而且那个剪刀它整体还是个透明的
Lucia: And the scissors are completely transparent.
Lucia: 特别不好找
Lucia: Really hard to find.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Lucia: 我说那个剪刀它整体是透明的
Lucia: 所以它也不好找
Lucia: So they're hard to find too.
Lucia: 拿起我的勺再吃一口
Lucia: I'll pick up my spoon and take another bite.
Lucia: 对那昨天晚上洒的
Lucia: Yeah, it was spilled last night.
Lucia: 我操啊完全找不到
Lucia: Damn, I can't find it at all.
Alice:现在只有一个了是吗
Alice: There's only one left now, right?
Lucia: 嗯而且是不好用的那个
Lucia: Yeah, and it's the one that's not good.
Alice:要不你先用着
Alice: Why don't you use it for now?
Lucia: 那个应该雨轩现在在用吧
Lucia: I think Yuxuan is using it now.
Lucia: 我也不知道
Lucia: I don't know either.
Lucia: 那个我也没找着
Lucia: I couldn't find it either.
Lucia: 就是所有的剪刀
Lucia: All the scissors...
Lucia: 都不见了
Lucia: Are missing.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Lucia: 到底啥情况靠
Lucia: What's going on, damn it.
Alice:要不用这个
Alice: How about using this one?
Lucia: 这个我昨天也用了
Lucia: I used this one yesterday too.
Lucia: 但是他没有捡到
Lucia: But it didn't work well.
Lucia: 灵活就我昨天切瓶子的时候用了
Lucia: I used it to cut a bottle yesterday.
Lucia: 我刚把它放到这其实
Lucia: I just put it here actually.
Lucia: 我靠好奇怪啊
Lucia: This is so weird.
Lucia: 他怎么能就没有了呢
Lucia: How could it just disappear?
Lucia: 我在群里问一下吧
Lucia: I'll ask in the group chat.
Alice:就蒸蛋蒸的不错
Alice: The steamed egg turned out well.
Lucia: 啊怎么哦
Lucia: Ah, what's going on?
Lucia: 在这里应该刚有谁拆快递用了
Lucia: Someone must have used it to open a package.
Lucia: 那我先上去把那个剪一下
Lucia: I'll go upstairs and check.
Lucia: 找到了
Lucia: （歌词）大雨在梦
Lucia: (Lyrics) Heavy rain in the dream
Lucia: （歌词）看海天一色听风起雨落
Lucia: (Lyrics) Watching the sea and sky, listening to the wind and rain
Lucia: （歌词）执子手吹散苍茫茫烟波
Lucia: (Lyrics) Holding hands, blowing away the misty waves